at long last we're returning to an old
show of ours but in a brand new way
movie recipes is back and this time it's
delicious I couldn't stomach any
more of that crap I was making at home
so we asked a few celebrity chefs to see
if they could do better and holy SH was
that direct decision in the new series
you'll see Chris and I discussing movies
while talented chefs prepare meals
inspired by them on the community table
channel you can learn more about the
dishes and the chefs who created them so
make sure you check that out and now
without further ado sometimes watching a
movie isn't enough you also want to eat
that movie that's why there's movie
recipes today we're with Chef Dale
levitski at cinema in Nashville
Tennessee my wrestlers called cinema
because our location is from a 1946
movie theater art deco theme so we
restored it into a restaurant the most
rewarding thing about cooking is that
every every day is like Groundhog Day
it's it's a reset button every day is
different different things you know
different hits the fan different things
go great I get to make people happy I
get to you know goof around in my
kitchen and just play with food we have
challenged him with making a meal fit
for a king the Lion King
to be specific chef Levitsky is chosen a
list of essential ingredients that will
do just that
they are millet it's cultivated in
Africa you get it right pork Pumbaa is
exceptionally worry-free no and eggs to
make the hakuna frittata let's get
crackin
Lion King biking the gigantic huge hit
18 1994 I think the only animated Disney
movie left that doesn't already have a
live-action adaptation in production
yeah
although yeah you know it is a Broadway
stage musical so there is sort of a live
version of it considering the last time
we did this and what he gave us this
could be lion
I've actually heard of people eating
lion before people are up in arms about
that line I got shot so maybe it's not
the best yeah climate to be cooking like
probably not I don't know but if the
lines already dead yeah what are you
gonna do I mean you just come on a
deadline on the road yeah nobody's gonna
be blaming you three
they're making me feel like scar has
ruined this place right so it's a barren
wasteland there's no grass everybody's
starving it rains all the time and then
Simba appears and everything goes back
to normal rest at Leela's like Glinda
the Good Witch came in and oh get or
something have you ever tried to grow
grass I've got a spot on my lawn and
I've been trying to grow grass for like
five years yeah well you have any Jeremy
Irons movies here well let's just go say
maybe I just need that like get a lion
to come by and then why I wonder if
they're not thinking about doing a
live-action Lion King where they use
real nature footage and voiceover let's
face it real Idol everything's remake of
all except Finding Nemo he couldn't do
that live-action unless you have like
robot fish
here we go gentlemen
yeah Oh oh my god looks awesome oh this
is oh please tell me when I'm about to
enjoy um the Lion King so hakuna
frittata oh and I used millet seed which
is a grain cultivated in Africa so it's
technically it's bird seed here but it's
actually pretty good to eat
so it's a baked millet frittata with and
we're in the south so barbecue pork
fried okra some broccoli and then a
pretty so the nice little spicy barbecue
sauce so it's got a little bit of heat a
little bit of Africa smells amazing all
right I'm ready cannot wait my mind and
body are ready I want to try millet eggs
Kikuyu frittata
oh man I love that sauce the sauce is
really good this is fried okra you said
yeah it's a wee pickle it so it's
pickled fried okra do I the best life or
what no matter good mmm oh I like and
I'm not like the food on camera guy but
it feels very much like a earthy wild
kind of I don't know that's what you're
going well that does the kind of guy
Pumbaa was so I'm we're eating Pumbaa
right yes yeah awesome don't stand
downwind after we're done what's the
experience like watching people eat food
mmm oh man
I've got the lovely bunch of coconuts
ready I'll just cut that randomly at the
end of the video like an outtake just
Jeremy singing that song